hanging out my parents a good bit lately
my dad
so like a month ago i get a series of
texts
that are photos
that is clearly somewhere on the human
body
but it's so punched in i don't know what
i'm looking at i'm like what is this
and it's like three photos in a row
i'm like what is this
and then he calls me he goes did you see
what i sent you i go yeah what is that
he goes that's between my scrotum and my
venus
what the [ __ ] man
and
he's like i got an infection down there
why are you sending me photos he's like
so you can see what i'm talking about
you could just say it
but you don't even know what you're
looking i know what i'm looking at i'm
like what is this
and then my mother's like
he makes me take pictures
and i show them to him and he goes
that's not good enough take another one
so he's like holding his legs up like a
child
changing a diaper and my mother is
snapping photos of an infection on his
taint oh my god and then he's like they
had to cut something out of me
i'm like all right got something out of
his taint yeah he had an infection he
said there and then i see him
three weeks ago
in person he comes to a show
and he's like come here let me show you
something i'm like all right and then on
an ipad it's the photos but full screen
i'm like you're taint again and he's
like did i show you this i go yeah we
talked about it you sent me these photos
i don't want to see my dad's [ __ ]
again
and he's like totally not getting how
crazy it is to send me that and then i
see him two days ago and he goes hey can
we show you something at dinner let me
show you something i go is it a photo of
your balls in your ass he's like yeah i
go we've been over this man i don't want
to see it i understand you have an
infection he sends him to so many people
he forgets he forgets who he said